my mom wants to be a co-signer for me to
be able to buy a property through an FHA
loan since I will be an first-time home
buyer I will be living in the property
but it will be divided and the other
side will be rented I was pre-approved
for
$325,000 I only make $36,000 a year as a
medical assistant and currently owe
$10,000 on student loans should I wait
before I make such a big investment yes
yes yes yes okay let's look at some red
flag here um number one you make
$36,000 $36,000 a year that's quite low
the reason you feel nervous and the
reason that you feel like you can't
breathe because it's literally like John
deloney would say it's your body telling
you there's something wrong and when
there's something wrong don't ignore it
let's look at what's wrong and you can
see what's what the problem is here